this person hit me up and said hey will
you do a corporate gig now if you're
going to ask christalia to do a
corporate gig the answer immediately no
why because corporate gigs are
notoriously horrible they're worse than
College gigs okay because corporate gigs
are a bunch of 60-year-old men that are
just sitting in a banquet hall somewhere
that happens to be in a [__] Hyatt
Regency or a Rison Inn and nine
60-year-old men come up and try and give
inspirational speeches about how they
came up in whatever business has to do
with this corporate gig and it's
emotional or it's very bad and then
there's like a life coach and then they
say oh yeah by the way here's a comedian
that you probably don't know about
because we aren't in his demo crystalia
and they give you the microphone and
you're like so
what's the difference between men and
women you ever go to [__] Home Depot
and it's like what and these
six-year-old men are like bring on Paul
Riser
though so it's an eat
shitton so I wanted to say no but then
I'm like you know what what is this
company I asked what the company was
it's a company called sphere rocket now
obviously that's a fake company because
that's not a real name but that was the
name they went with and that's and I
bought it and whatever and I said to
Kristen hey I'll do this gig if you come
with me and Calvin can come I want to I
want to buy him a cowboy hat and she was
like I would love to go to Texas so I
say it's on
[__] so I said yes they said
what are your stipulations I gave them a
bunch of stipulations and then they said
yes and so I said
okay so I say prepared this is going to
be [__] awful I said can I bring
somebody to [__] wet the room up for
me you know so Mike lenoi came wet the
room up for me I said he going to do 10
minutes you know they had a guy try and
stand up for the first time ever and
then Mike lenoi and then me so the guys
so we get there and they're like hi
welcome here's the Green Room the green
room is not a green room The Green Room
is just a room that [__] happens to
be there and they're like we have your
club soda and I was like oh that's
amazing I actually said I want to club
soda this is hilarious like I don't even
have a rider people was like what's your
Rider I'm like I don't know man what do
you think Cat Williams green M&M's and
don't look at me you know I just water
and
so if you make eye club soda and if you
make eye contact with me more than six
seconds I [__] my pants and you have to
clean it up deal sign on the bottom line
so
um so we get there and it looks fine you
know they're talking there's a life
coach talking and then another comedian
that's trying to do standup and it's you
know it's going about as well as you'd
think it's the first time you ever tried
doing standup but I can't tell how good
the [__] audience is cuz this guy's
on stage for the first time ever right
and I don't know I don't know how to
gauge the audience there's about 300
people 400 people there so I say all
right Mike go ahead and try not to do
too much crowd work
because I might have to [__] do it
right like lot of you guys may not know
this but as a
comedian like Last Resort in a
in a corporate gig in a company they
they really want you to roast them right
so so I'll that'll be my backup plan
because I want I'm supposed to do 45
[__] minutes and I can't roast them
for 45 [__] minutes right so I'm
going to start with material if that
doesn't go well then I'm just going to
have to roast them so I tell Mike dude
two do 10 minutes but don't do too much
crowd work cuz you might have to leave
that for me I'm going to be out there in
a SE of people that don't know who the
[__] I am or maybe they
do right but this is the [__] that's
going on through my mind so Mike goes
out there and starts crushing okay he
starts doing some crowd work which is
fine and it's going really well and then
he starts doing his material and he's
doing his like edgy stuff and it's
crushing so I'm like okay good at least
they're getable but also what if they
just like
Mike what if I'm out there he's doing 10
minutes he knows he's doing 10 minutes
he's got the confidence of hey I'm Mr
10minute guy here's my whole Hot Load
for 10 minutes and then your boy's got
to go up the Mr Hollywood oh
professional let's see what you got dude
for 45
minutes so I'm like [__] and now I'm
feeling it and yeah I just did the creek
in the cave and yeah I just did the
Vulcan gas company and yeah your boy
crushed a lot but this is a different
story and Corporation G corporate gigs
absolutely are you know they're
terrible so I get out there and I'm like
I'm going to do material I'm going to
get out there I'mma do my material Mike
wet up the stage just like he should
have like a professional I'mma get out
there and I'm going to [__] just do
my material and it's going to be smooth
sailing so I get out there and the first
thing I do is I say hey guys how you
doing hey look at this guy what's up
with this guy boom I'm In Crowd workor
already so I'm [__]
baby he immediately succumbs to the
pressure I yes
dude he immediately wants to take him
down to crushville I yes he's
insecure he's going up oh I'm going to
do this this this got my whole set list
ironed out in my head goes up and says
hey Guy what's your name ah yes
insecurity Peaks through the
veil he wanted to crush
suum he wanted to get to the set so s he
thought that maybe that he was going to
get up and do some crowd work and then
he thought that maybe he could ease his
way into some material
so he absolutely went up with a plan but
then life smacked him in the
[Music]
face but he's a professional right so
he's breathing within himself and he's
telling everyone about this new guy that
he's talking about doing crowd work and
he just
starts leveling the
place he just now you know me I don't
mince words but he just
starts order in a roof for this place
because this one's getting blown
off now you know I don't mince words I
like to be honest and I like to keep
[__] subtle but he just starts praying
for the third floor because they're
going to [__] Crush their spines when
they fall through the roof of this
Banquet Hall which happens to be on the
second
floor
so I make fun of this and I got a lot
and I noticed Mike lenoi like a
[__] homie is out there getting
it on camera he's getting a lot of it on
camera and your boy did so I start so
now I do 10 minutes of crowd work and
then I'm like let me just test the
waters on this material let me just test
the waters okay I test the
waters water's freezing
cold I test the water
water's freezing
cold was crushing with the crowd work go
back to some material
material water's freezing
cold so I go okay maybe let me check the
water a little later get back to some
[__] crowd
work and now I got to start praying for
the people on the third floor again and
I'm not religious I hope I'm doing a
good job but I'm not religious but this
roof's going to give
out do you have hey crowd do you have on
your fire retardant
suits then it's going to be a
doozy so I do 20 minutes more of crowd
work I'm on stage for 30 minutes I start
to dip into some
material water's freezing
cold and I don't B I'm not bombing
material but it's just not what they
want so I get up to 45 minutes and I've
probably done four minutes of material
if that I would say I did 41 minutes of
roasting this audience and they're
loving it
okay and I finally say well guys it's
about time to wrap it up and the CEO
stands up from the back of the room and
says hey
Chris and I say yeah and he says got a I
don't he says got a message for you
and I go
uhoh and his the person who put the show
together walks up slowly to the room and
I'm like what the [__] is happening she
walks right up to the stage and goes
like
this and I'm like okay I guess she wants
the microphone so I give it to her and
she says the CEO of the company would
like to offer you and then she says a
sum of money to do 15 extra minutes
would you accept and I grabbed the
microphone and I said well I guess I'm a
hooker
today so I did it and they put a timer
on for the 15 extra minutes and the
timer counted down boy did I feel like a
[__]
[Music]
hooker but isn't that everyone doing a
job you know you're just doing it for
that stack aren't you um and it was fun
and I got off stage bro by the way the
entrepreneur the guy had the whole
company was hilarious man and I made fun
of it I roasted everybody but dude there
was a company there was a guy the Entre
the [__] CEO of the company was 24
years old and he had a [__] shirt on
that said
entrepreneur alien secretly trying to
take over the
world un it was unbelievable dude so I
have listen I have it I have the a lot
of the set I don't have all of the set
but I have a lot of it I'm thinking of
uploading it to the more christalia
Channel on YouTube I don't know if I
should because it's from far away or not
but if you leave a comment and if this
gets enough comments under this video
saying we want to see the crowdwork
video for me at this Corporation sphere
rocket then I'll think about uploading
it